- Yeah, I know a
PA on Transparent,
so I think I know what
trans people go through.
- Stop.
You've participated
in a trolling cliche.
The hall pass.
What's that?
Your cousin's wife's
uncle fought in Vietnam?
Wow.
You must be the world's leading
authority on the history
of communism in Southeast Asia.
You know, using your alignments
to make your point doesn't work.
This whole, "I can't be racist,
my best friend is black,"
stuff has been going
on for a long time.
But thank you for updating
it and bringing it online.
It's just a shame it's never
worked, and it never will.
But I'm sure you know
all about never working.
'Cause you once talked to a
homeless dude at a bus stop.